how could hold down this fort and I
guarantee if we told all the fans some
might appreciate it if you took a break
for five weeks
excuse me sir no I'm just saying are you
trying to [ __ ] replay no not at all
not I'm saying a lot I guess
hold on forward yeah I get to you if we
told the fans hey Brian shooting Wonder
Woman - so he's not gonna be in town for
five weeks so it's gonna be Brennan and
guest Theo von
so what we're gonna do is give me
Brendan I got weeks you're I don't want
to say there'd be an uproar of happiness
but I think everyone would understand
and then I think everyone understand
when you get that text two weeks and it
says hey bro don't bother coming back
I'm I'm hurt and I'm slowly being
replaced no I'm just saying for reals
though and take your hands up selling
art touch me like that again
don't touch me that was Frank Grillo but
good news Theo von just step stopped in
to say hello he goes I'm just gonna
bother you guys and he's here to do just
a couple things I guess he's gonna do a
couple of impressions the oh well can
you do I think you have a crystal
imprint you just burst in here oh my god
[Music]
good dude oh my god bad Jesus so bad is
that Chris Christie my his hair is
longer than mine and it's true I swear
to God for a second I thought that was
Chris D'Elia oh my god I'm so on it now
what would be can you do an impression
of like say me let me see Bryan Callen
yeah my challenge to be deeper
okay that looks that smell animals
that's amazing romanian beekeeper I say
Allah I thought I first saw you I
thought is there two counts of yesterday
why were you going like this with your
fingers really push it in home in the
air like holding the world Brenda in it
that's so good that's always doesn't
like my do you have a Brandon impression
let me see um this is so spot on do you
feel like you just heard you died
obviously look like Brandon I live now
do you look like 21 Jump Street you look
a you got [ __ ] up on 21st Avenue dude
you look like Lenny from of mice and
Massimo you goddamn will not retire from
Hot Topic did you locate the 50 year old
vegan bro get your life together man you
came back from Nashville and you changed
man I did yeah you change bro it might
just be the reflection off this hot
strap right here do not be keep your
life together dude I don't have any
friends send me peaches and [ __ ] yeah we
got a lot of issues man I have issues
yeah you ever seen yourself yeah you
might be right
100% bro dude you know you slowly turn
into [ __ ] I mean you're here like
that first is a mullet they just have
full-blown shaking oh this is Swayze
dude yeah it's lazy bro so many people
stop and ask about the hair and
with the hair I could be pushing like a
senior citizen in a wheelchair no bike-o
who's this [ __ ] yeah yeah anybody I'm
like what are you even asking for like I
saw the hair and then just respected
this old person you know like the hair
is a lot of it definitely like you think
joy cause like I think of like lesbian
stepmom a little bit like a little bit
of a southern lesbian stepmom did you
have to go be well I don't know what you
hate on that I think dope like I feel
like if they're doing a sitcom on ABC
and you walked in on a dress they're
like this your new stepmom and people
like oh that's cool doodie you look
right back roads you get a job doing
construction in West Hollywood for the
rest of your life bro look at you dude
you look like a do that eats burgers and
just carries around a [ __ ] shotgun
look whole have you seen some of you
guys are probably listening on radio you
can't see this man radio on ham radio to
race corner would race quarter woodchuck
do you [ __ ] me
you look like you were that orange juice
and [ __ ] never touch the kid and I have
worked at a smoothie place you know I
would never do anything wild to a kid
and I babysat overnight three times
dude I would not let you babysit my kid
well that's fine actually I was oh I
wouldn't want any tails son because I'll
be you know oh did you feel me okay
chopsticks boy
these [ __ ] karate makers right here
bruh like a chimp [ __ ] perked up when
he saw these [ __ ] stone cold killers
hit the air so no you need your back on
that that old New Orleans sauce you know
back on that deck of D you seem like the
toughest [ __ ] at a Claire's boutique
[Laughter]
bro you stole the story you a [ __ ]
busboy you inject each other on the silo
highway then [ __ ] each other
yeah we're just supposed to breathe like
it's normal
just go dude in the south on the side of
a New Orleans highway sucking each other
off
no gir that it took you looking at an
eight-year-old boy got an infection from
an ogre and that's where he's at right
now 89 yeah there and this thing is
anything you look you look like Macho
Man Randy Savage we had AIDS man Randy
tragic like the war if he just no heat
shirt in it what dude watch your tone
you look like him if he were in the
second a man your baton Swiss dude dude
you look like Lenny from of mice and
Massimo woman's don't touch me dude and
it's the third time it's happened in
here dude five times dude I'm calling
the police I won't hold you down and
shave your head dude look I grew up in
the molester belt
five times you touch me I'm calling the
cops five I'm saying about if I give you
a couple of I'm saying you have women's
band-aids on the back here for you these
are major band-aid blisters yeah oh yeah
ready for them boards is that haircut
come with have you seen his [ __ ]
haircut unbelievable yeah both my seven
and five-year-old nephew dude let me ask
you with that lesbian haircut do you get
a discount on Subaru Outback how's that
word I just enforce green or how does
that work
dude this haircuts phenomenal I think
I'm not mad at it bro yeah this guy's at
worst bro oh you're gonna die soon you
have a gym like i don't have a gym like
this isn't a big deal dude you should
really be worried about it you already
look like you look like all of the who's
a frat Ellie's from you look like every
one of the Fratellis who's the Fratellis
from you look Lebanese you look like mom
and sell rats you look again on the side
of the river that cell rat dude you look
like something that's gonna audition to
be one of the Bugle Boy that what's the
who's who the people that Rob screws
your mcdhh up oh who were those guys
that big guy
beagle boys beagle boys they were dope
yeah duct tape Lord oh yeah they were
dope man costume there they are the big
oh my god oh yeah they look like yeah
that's my squad bro the Beagle boys bro
who seems more racist you think Rendon
that's really what I say deal by a
longshot
really but you're wearing camo dude
you're in camo woogie these are enough
camo capris on these aren't jeans capris
on they was some with some Under Armour
shoes with nike socks Camel women capris
and a woman's hair what [ __ ] row you
have a camera you can only get from
being a cafeteria female cafeteria
worker who's abusing steroids are you
lately on the job you broke up you look
like you make sloppy joe there's me like
that you look like you make the best
sloppy joe in LA right now you look like
you raised two kids named sloppy joe
dude if you [ __ ] little boy after two
girls named Diane what are you talking
about dude I'm growing this for a kid
dude who has cancer but also has a
four-wheeler that kid's gonna be cool as
[ __ ] bro locks for lust bro that's what
I'm growing this [ __ ] out
9 year old with no with [ __ ] who's
definitely low in the chromosomes but
he's down the [ __ ] and not afraid to go
in a 5 wheel drive but I'll cut my hair
for the dude we're doing I'm just saying
you look like a blatant lesbian
cafeteria worker you have women's blend
in with the [ __ ] leg I didn't create
safety pads I didn't create these
[ __ ] band and a bro and the racists
right I didn't do that I just want to
cover up my blisters bro your blisters
your lesbian mom haircut women your
judgment and your racist ways Pizza
insulting the whole finally kid team he
talk they look different than Domino's
what is it it's a board game for
children you're in there eating what a
[ __ ] creep there's kids and they're
playing games and you're in there
looking for [ __ ] black olive in
mushroom what a that's what I'm saying
when you die get those [ __ ] to get
the hands up dude Oh No
wig dough huh I want a wig already got a
wig bro okay you can't talk about
somebody's here
well you have you Bri out lesson fair
cut 70s haircut bro I got the only
person I know with this haircut that's a
lie I got the power in the front I got
the glory in the bag dude I'm just a
sharecropper brother let's be in the
back and the dick in the food God's grow
a son dude if your [ __ ] haircut was a
choice on Great Clips no one would take
you no one besides lesbian oh dude
beautiful let's take the field cut
lesbians dude right now and the crazy
thing is you are all my might have the
hair you have all the other elements of
a [ __ ] real lesbian dude do you have
the hair and the face no you tell me
your nose doesn't look lesbian I knows I
have a nose of a brother due to straight
up oh brother no brothers I've ever seen
I'll be black Greek guy no little say
czar bruh you feel me beats a [ __ ]
Pizza [ __ ] oh wow okay little say hard
say for know where that
where's the [ __ ] black Greek boys at
that little saison say czar onward
goodbye the sweater you even in no way I
would buy the sweater
you wouldn't know really you wouldn't
buy the sweater you seem like a guy that
would bro
I would not seem like the dude that buys
everything bro every day I see of an a
different pair of [ __ ] shoes on look
like British shoes or something like he
this guy's feet living Britain and his
body lives here in America more gonna
[ __ ] yellow do you know where this
comes from
you know wheelchair airforces or
whatever the eldest you have yeah
Benedict Arnold x9s or whatever all this
[ __ ] I want some Benedict Arnold X these
orange candy come on [ __ ] you know uh
keyless entry [ __ ] low tops like what
the [ __ ] is going on bro bro you have a
[ __ ] Juwanna
Sacajawea [ __ ] disband on right now
with one made this for me yet I'm save
America a Native American made that for
you yeah no we're anything anything
anyone gives you all [ __ ] with is a
the Bounty Hunter oh yeah Judy em look
like brothers oh dude hey can you met
your dad haha [ __ ] dude bro don't
[ __ ] touch me he dyes his hair dude
and he has asthma too and he uses the
n-word we have a couple things in common
oh you guys look his wife looks like a
rockin yeah it's like her stomach just
[ __ ] hooked to her chest and then
didn't got a divorce like what she eats
it just goes yeah your tits are taking
[ __ ] your old dudes ass on our chest
that's insane
don't worry Jerry you [ __ ] bloated
Italian look I got Italian do that
drowned and then just still lived take a
Persian dude on test 200 this staring
straight into the Sun you can't even
open your [ __ ] eyes dude I'm about to
put quarters in your face bro your ass
Friday night you and your dad Dog the
Bounty Hunter go get a red box and get
some pants for your tits
do you see this like these 2's bro I
just call her tits
[Music]
it's just a head
and then two toothpick legs at the
bottom like your kid drew at you
like a third-grade drawling yeah like
two grapefruits and a stick at the
bucket and [ __ ] she looks like a
drawing of a way perverted kid
four-year-old good [ __ ] draw a troll
oh my god
but yeah yeah you gotta get him on the
show here the office you would be dude
you guys call him up for a living you
guys don't have a bat signal you know
put a big light with a can of dip in the
air and he'll show up he's from where
I'm from he's from Hawaii huh that's
things from Aurora but he lives in
Hawaii yeah how he's always like hey
brah it's like whoa we don't talk like
that
I'm temper but he's been there for like
a year or so knee just took over their
language we gotta leave him for Tam yeah
people love him out there dude
you didn't get in trouble or some [ __ ]
yeah he said the N word to his daughter
on the phone one time he called her an
n-word no I was talking about some yeah
he said it once and then got fired yeah
yeah yeah you can't have it man his
hairs better than yours oh man that's
cool that's goals though you know I'm
saying like you know his wife just grows
hair pretty [ __ ] hooks it in the back
you also have those glasses like what
the [ __ ] he doing you have the same
nose I think you guys are very similar
just talking about reality shows and I
love Dog the Bounty Hunter
they replay him on any I watch him
non-stop then he must be making some
money or they are somebody residuals I
don't know I bet at a certain point he
probably did have some residuals cuz it
was all based on him looking at those
tits again and get out of the blue to
the blue food go to him with his shirt
off oh yeah damn dawg Wow I bet ah I bet
he takes crazy dumps too bro yeah but
it's out of a window that guy's insane
nobody should think criminals man I bet
he [ __ ] already swims out of the ocean
just shits into an alligator's mouth
okay he's a wild cat dude i ah man i
good show though if you don't scene in a
hot second look at titties
that's unbelief I'll get it that's
whether she call it dog into it should
be Dog the Bounty Hunter that's what it
shouldn't bounce and dude if I was a kid
I would never grow up if I had those
tits in my mouth we ever I or or you'd
be like six eight Jack just sucking on
them tip at nine years oh those music
say those can feed a goddamn village
just one titty enough for everybody
did you could put out a fire with milk
with those [ __ ] tits there that's
insane I bet she is a savage in the sack
[Laughter]
dude I don't know if I could [ __ ] that
lady man oh you could get them big old
things out slap in your face she starts
saying come on boy come on deal come on
son let's do it man's voice that's us
she talks
ha ha and then and then she has at it
she squishing those fat tits but she
can't look he has on those black gloves
she's always wears the fingerless but
has her nails proper done yeah I was a
real problem that's it all the time your
nails are proper like that 60-year old
dude at the gym who wears those fishnet
yeah she's still rockin that [ __ ] did I
used to rock those fishnets when I first
started working out they were dope can
we see her in the pink right there chin
demon and the pink and he's in Oulu yeah
yeah person they're morphing into the
same liquid and [ __ ] hair though that
is beautiful it's like when they eat
goes to his stomach because of her
titties yeah they ever do it's like a
bipartisan digestive system yeah there's
just one in the same you know some
people starting to look like their dogs
mm-hmm there his stomach starting look
like her - yeah she starts to look like
her dog the bounty hunter imagine being
a bounty hunter in Hawaii first of all
nobody could go anywhere it's a [ __ ]
island the [ __ ] this is the easiest
way to catch criminal ever
yeah small I quit oh he's lazy
hell I met that's [ __ ] lazy it's like
being a Wrangler in an uh like in a
hamster case like finishing a pets boy
it's [ __ ] easy man that's in Denver's
a beast for him so he's at [ __ ] this for
safety by he's bad at his job he got to
go uphill I never understood that show
like if Dog the Bounty Hunter he's not a
legal [ __ ] officer there's no he's no
badge nothing that you'll have to stop
they put up with us like [ __ ] you bro
no call the cops you [ __ ] [ __ ] get
your big titty why the [ __ ] is these
cameras
[ __ ] dude I'm a criminal [ __ ] me
you have tasers how about shoot both of
you I never understood I think he gets
to be able to look at the whole wife's
tits and then everybody get some and
then he handcuffs oh yeah and then when
in the car they give him that Jerry
Seinfeld like my one minute they get in
a speech oh yeah you know you're not
doing the right thing brah you know you
don't go down this row brah yeah man he
was a drug addict to was he really yeah
so he's like I've been there brah I've
been there you don't want this brah I'm
saying brah to everyone I love I
celebrated man dude I gotta watch him
again man yeah you got him man you guys
look similar I got to get back into that
we don't look that somewhere but I
wouldn't mind I being jacked as him and
the future I wouldn't mind having more
ABS though yeah yeah you might well his
titty starting to sack a little bit but
mmm but not she just needs to get her
tits out of our face oh missings are
coming key wow what is that is that a
tell you titty guy I don't know man
these days it's you know you you know
there's just you don't have to pick
these days I don't think there's just
some tits are just correct like I didn't
like whenever they had like a big girl
back in the day and she was like oh I
got these tits and it's like nice just
kind of wait yeah yeah and that's just
it's proportionate to the rest of your
body that rolls it's just two extra
rolls with a nipple on them yeah yeah
yeah you just got way too right I don't
know pal
I got a deal Vaughn bring them in who
the [ __ ] is that
oh [ __ ] bro oh [ __ ]
and you notice producers with them you
know steve on himself you got a flat ass
so so Theo
i-i've never met you you you got a lot
of hairspray in your hair that gymnasium
that's natural gas Teddy okay
you know where'd you get that [ __ ]
belt feel this right here yeah this one
that set that [ __ ] like online like
how much is that [ __ ] away I don't want
to touch it
well look if Brandon showers right there
one spinning so much money on his
goddamn socks maybe that has something
nice maybe I'll turn this real gold OS
on a percent almost real gold that's
gold 24-karat so use your head you know
that belt is fake but that's fake news
fake belt no this is a you tickle that
nickel baby this is real stuff right
here man and I'm out there doing the
Lord's work I'm robbing Peter to pay
Paul Zynga's baby all day you know that
horsey all day baby I'm uncomfortable
he's a southern steel baby okay so let's
do a test right now who's the guest of
the year like ask questions do assess
maybe do it all okay I said as an
impersonal River the fans did say that
Theo von no fan said it's you out know
Maryland voted baby no they didn't yeah
you're be white and blue tuefel baby you
know right Mike you're being a little
bit of a sore loser right now generate
and go because it was a little sorry it
was Theo labs like Rosalia well he's on
crystal Lee he went in [ __ ] he wasn't
even in the conversation now we see eye
to eye on something
I invented guests of the year I think
I'm sixteen didn't win it 2016 2041 it
and then you came in here and you made a
belt up for yourself my friend
do you have a strap daddy he's asking
you I'd like to claim this thing's heavy
man this thing probably weighs about
nine pounds I got that from Vince
McMahon oh this is the or son
that it may be so yeah baby welcome is
Happy Days maybe I'm the Fonz with the
bronze daddy you feel me I'm the Fonz
and if you are you blind - do you want a
shot [ __ ] you're moving like Stevie
Wonder I've got butter this is real
butter and someone's getting in my eyes
baby let me ask you a question I would
like to do a test right now I was like
an old blockbuster I used to go to spit
booths when I was younger
what's the German piss bars are but
what's the spit food you know chicken
but I've never played anything like that
spit boom now in New York City what's
this pitbulls Brian come on use your
[ __ ] brain
it was the peat booths on 42nd and you
go and watch movies and guys were
jerk-offs a bit booze all you went to
spit booth yes he smells like Lube and
hairspray that's America smell like baby
that's Aqua Net it smells like a
blockbuster in Aurora Colorado Oh baby
that's diesel gasoline brother wash my
legs with DS now do a quick test like I
was like a thing you're like guess I'm
here and like will let the fans go dude
you know we're your fans did it do you
know boating work Sports Chalet that's
Halloween well this I did get it on sale
the fans voted and he knows it he knows
it and by the way we and we're doing
stem cells donations for Brian this week
this strap will be continuing to tour
America I'm just stopping it by right
here because I wanted it so mr. Michael
Rapaport what the strap looks like
got that [ __ ] down he's got it out
here's the terrace-flat ass though
watts kill you he still was like the
wheel oh yeah did I fell asleep one time
this cop wakes me up right he goes did
you did you see him do you know where
they're at I'm like what the [ __ ] no
idea what's going on right he goes
somebody called in two wolves were
fighting in the street here dude I'm at
an intersection of this dead town
browser I lived in this side town for a
little water in high school
fell asleep at the [ __ ] wheel right
so I'm dead asleep cop wakes me up right
he's like did you see it and I almost
like what I'm just thinking was you know
Who am I and he's like talking to
somebody else to other guys probably
said cross the street you know and he's
like - somebody called it in - wolves
fighting in the intersection and I'm
like thinking uh we don't even have
wolves in Louisiana you know so how are
you really out here looking for that but
also students but also m82 was riding
driver who's obviously stopped any by
card if you see anything let us know and
they were out no problem officer
damn you old joke is [ __ ] I mean while
they're on acid because they're there
see you know a cop I used to have a
problem fall asleep at the wheel we were
driving to Vegas on a road trip and he's
like don't fall asleep I'm like I got
this man and I'm driving and I fall
asleep and you know what woke me up
Wow you don't want me on you right off
him snoring what Kalen no my buddy buddy
that's you [ __ ] dangerous here I'm
like what the [ __ ] I was driving yeah my
friend tell me if that starts to happen
take the tongue take your try this take
the tip of your tongue and tickle the
roof of your mouth
and guess what it's never worked one
triack oh well I'm not tired though
right now yeah my tire right now so I'll
be awake either way
okay
tons of things out there don't work
touch yourself roll down the windows
loud music if I'm if he don't face
[ __ ] [ __ ] I pull over dude when I was
young I fell asleep at the the premiere
of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles my dad
made two lines in to our lines I fell
asleep there we went to a monster truck
rally I fell asleep there oh I fell
asleep at Game seven when Tumbo beat the
Seattle Seahawks I mean see how I fell
asleep in Smashing Pumpkins concert
that's a great concert yeah well I mean
it could have been I fell asleep I fell
asleep at the wheel probably at least 40
times I fell asleep during driver's ed
while I was driving the car as a driver
the guy operate that's not the man the
adult with the license like you're gonna
fall asleep I was like no way dude 16
seconds later [ __ ] dead asleep bro we
had to pull over
there's no music right you're not
falling asleep everywhere falling asleep
indoors outdoors fell asleep oh no I've
fallen asleep some really good place did
you have those friends when you'd fall
asleep they'd [ __ ] with you I hate that
[ __ ] I draw on your face a dick no we
didn't have any of that dude all
pictures dicks in your mouth or vice
versa sleep no [ __ ] here our Vice
Principal Raleigh Coleman it was an
urban gentleman and who had a a ie black
jheri-curl
who could have been black he was dark
Jerry Kern gentleman he used to sleep in
the trunk of his car at [ __ ] recess
did he go sneak over about a teacher
parking lot just cuz you don't want to
ensue yep and he would tie off his trunk
with a little rope so it was about three
inches high and he'd get in look at that
[ __ ] this dark though you know idea
it'd be hot yeah in Louisiana I don't
know why he liked it but I think he just
felt comfort in there somehow you know
maybe he didn't have a parent I don't
know what some of his issues the jerry
curl would explain a little bit but
curled up boy I don't belt right here
something Chris D'Elia will never have
dude and he can have all kind of stuff
he has someone said in his house he has
a ice-cream maker and if someone said
that that is a Slurpee machine Oh
Krystal he has an ice-cream maker in his
house and doesn't even eat dairy that's
why I'm just there well that's that's
overabundance and that's rich people
doing rich [ __ ] yes
he has for couches dude and there's a
man out there and a woman out there
trying to make love on a floor somewhere
while that [ __ ] sitting there
were for couches welcome dude the only
ain't a champ brony never will be
oh [ __ ] and you know it come see him
D'Elia huh
come see me dude he's too busy doing you
know doing whatever he does there's rich
Oh being rich dude someone said he got a
jacket made out of money he made a bunch
of just made by a jacket made out of
money you know it's crazy he wanders
around his house hiding money probably
around and then blindfold himself and
going looking for his own dude I saw
Chris microwave a wad of cash before
yeah microwave it he's changed man when
I met him he was a different guy he was
gentle nice cared about his animals
someone said his animals he has like a
group a pet company that comes and takes
him and just brings him around for his
Instagram oh dude and him and Bobby Lee
this is a true story used to go down to
Mexico Chris and my beliefs you got on
to Mexico to get involved with who knows
what
but they used to go watch Mexican
comedians perform and steal their
material and bring it back up to America
how crazy is that his fighting words and
they would steal the Mexica means we
talk in Spanish they translate and steal
it back to America who knows what
happened dude I'm just telling you what
I've heard and this is just around the
water huh that's around the water this
around the water cooler but I say this
does a lot of people drinking around the
Waller water cool yeah the water crews
be Nancy Scott is Ali Wong if you guys
are going to the Comedy Store
hey you don't [ __ ] oh D [ __ ] in nose
dude don't say though sorry it's not
it's something it's dude how dare you
not come on our show get over here now
Bobby Bobby Lee just knocked on our
[ __ ] door Bobby is the best shirts
man last night shirt was fire too bro
what's up first of all don't don't walk
in don't walk in like you're you walk
around like you're on hot coals you you
act all dainty is he gonna be mean bro
and why is your warrior pants a guy came
up to me at the Comedy Store and Kevin
said you know you're really important to
me and I never forgot what you said to
Bobby when he was on your podcast and
and you said to him you got to keep
going
I'm sorry for the [ __ ] boys Bobby Bobby
Bobby
Bobby's Bobby's jeans Bobby's jeans are
$300 Bobby's were 300 our ladings bro
will do guess bro you came back from
China that's not true I have a very
strong voice yes I do
Bobby thanks fat man your podcast
appreciated man have a good night have a
good day guys man they crashed our
podcast don't ever open the door again
to those people
Bobby Lee looking button-down there's
always one of his buttons is open like
just doesn't give a [ __ ] he's so funny
did you did you roll out of the couch
yeah these very games there's a hot girl
they have a podcast he's amazing um
funny man
moving on he's [ __ ] up our whole show
didn't they great a lot of dudes up in
here the real business is around just so
people know we're in like an office
building and then me and Brian took this
over first podcast ever being there and
then Thiel followed us here and now it's
bit of a [ __ ] show but the rest of the
offices are like
real nine-to-fivers trying to work it
out here that's right that's right
we don't care though we don't care we
live on the edge only it like a couple
of Christian boys if you don't believe
in him you go to hell I hope you enjoy a
lake of fire forever you can tell me the
odds are you're not gonna influence
Indian children do it I don't think a
lot of Indian kids like it to be like I
want to [ __ ] you know look like a
French Paul Bunyan when I get older
no I'm saying do you look like Paul
Bunyan if you just drank champagne all
day and never did any forestry because
man you don't know yourself that well
you gotta get a better mirror man using
[ __ ] cheap mirrors you got $111 socks
and cheap mirrors dude Wow bro man you
got to get out more
knees and mirrors regularly I need some
new mirrors you've been raised in a
clown house you just it'll cure Down
syndrome bruh I beat it
there's a lot of rumors in my town I got
beat down syndrome yeah well that's
inspiring man that's how I felt when I
heard him because I didn't start them
and that's one of the things as
beautiful about sometimes being in a
small town is you know it doesn't take a
lot of you to hear [ __ ] about yourself
yeah you get more feedback yeah in LA
some guy walks from a by you in the hall
like aw look at this [ __ ] chimpanzee
you know but you never know you never
hear it but in a small towns only nine
people I know we hear it now though
these days social media yeah they get
you you get a lot of haters on there I'm
sure I'm sure I don't see a lot of it
but I'm sure do you um I don't think so
I mean I get I get some stuff I guess
but I don't think anything I really
trying to think of something I'm tough
to hate on you cuz you're not really
like I'll get like I'll get some hate
obviously what am i you're easier to
hate what will you
I mean there's just more I mean like if
I know you know
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you look bro you only think about
exactly what you look like you like some
drinks keels at the airport do you look
troubled
you drink some more bottles of keels
hand lotion at the airport you got
issues man
Oh artists we draw some mock up a decent
image of this you look like Lenny from
Of Mice and Men but if we're filmed in
like like if it were filmed probably
more film look like the biggest [ __ ]
kid in Sacramento fro and that's true
dude and I mean and I don't mean that in
a mean way your though the beat down
syndrome
you're right there Lenny small right
there you look like straight-up Lenny
this jack
dude you lookin at you you're like -
dude who if everybody's escaped in
prison you'd be like nah got a I got to
be up in the morning for breakfast don't
say like you good to do this like
doesn't get that everybody's I probably
do didn't have makeovers run from dude I
remember my mom actually want a perm one
time on the radio that was young and
some other [ __ ] from across town said
it was hers I don't just be from
dumpling it's so much hair in his neck
he would gel it down for the hurts
because you didn't want to shave it off
because it was his hair and it was like
a thing against God you joke down the
thighs
oh he jealous whole neck hair down you
might want to gel the your you guys see
out a duck tail hanging out the back I
look like [ __ ] man you know but nobody
expects anything out of me that's the
best thing you don't think you sure what
people look you know people ask where's
the honey guy you know this obviously
but you look like you've been stung by
bees do I look blow this it looks like
you try to drink honey right out the
hive and a bunch of these guys they seen
a small [ __ ] blood you're small for
sure dude I'd be sore - [ __ ] 200 bees
we're babysitting my face all the time
[ __ ] a bunch of bees where do you
live that bro in a comb
you gotta tighten up bro you're gonna
get diabetes day you gotta tighten up
bro you got that Beeson grown old rat
oh you look like the Rat King
you look mound or pitch okay but not the
cool Master Splinter one no you have no
other choice
like the one in that Christmas play like
that cool man Nutcracker the ranking oh
you look like the leader of the people
in Vegas who sleep on their bow you know
there's a community underground you look
like they're the voice of the
underground I look like I run the
underground air B&B now you have a belt
to make you official oh you just have
this giant [ __ ] rat ever put in the
[ __ ] don't pass the Playboy that's
what I'm gonna make it is that on the
back don't pet the playboy dude well the
scary part is I start to think is this
the best i'ma look you know yeah I'm
going downhill me yeah another year
before people like oh [ __ ]
shops falling off like a [ __ ]
and Calas been falling apart man bless
his heart did I saw all the other day
and man I don't know if they're not I
mean I thought he was a ok he just went
to an early movie he looked like a
senior you know it was just weird I
caught him at a glimpse it was like oh
wow if the light hits his face right
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah look somebody
get this guy some jello just don't get
this guy a nice warm mask in some
cucumber you know well a lot of it's
just stress I think a lot of his skin
falls off of his body a lot it seems
like because of stress I almost you ever
seen that movie death become sir
mmm would they take that that that
potion and that makes them stay alive
forever but there's bodies that can't
keep out so the falling apart like they
have to spray paint their skin and [ __ ]
and never seen death becomes is it cool
hell yeah it's a classic
ah you never heard of it death becomes
her but that becomes there is a classic
for everybody classic classic what movie
becomes her bed for him for
oh my god
Meryl Streep oh I love Meryl Streep dude
well death becomes her one of her
biggest movies dude I'd meet two with
Meryl Streep bro if she named him unto
me not I wouldn't do it the other way
but I'd watch her jerk-off into a plant
Oh